Now, is it true
that you guys are on an SNL lady text chain?
Is this true?
We do chat
with one another a lot.
Okay, what is it like
Really?
to be on that text chain?
It's great, 'cause we...
There's laughs, advice, and--
There's laughs and advice and a lot of common experience,
which I think is- it's a weird sorority that we're in,
so it's nice to have that shared experience stay relevant
in our grown up lives.
Can I ask, I mean, this morning,
Chris Miller, my partner of 20 years,
he was filming in the hallway to get to your name plaque
and talk about Debbie Downer.
What is your favorite character
and memory for both of you from SNL?
I had another thought when you said that,
when you were talking about Debbie Downer.
It is amazing, I was watching a movie with my son
that was filmed in Australia, three or four years ago,
and out of the blue, in the movie, in Australia,
this little-known film, the guy goes, "Okay, Debbie Downer,"
about somebody, and it was like,
to know this person that created this character
that saturated culture so much
that an Australian film would have a casual reference
to Debbie Downer was like,
Debbie Downer.
It's an amazing thing.
It is amazing.
It's wild that it's the same person,
or we talk about Tina and Mom Jeans
or these vernacular moments that are part
of our bigger culture.
How did you come up
with Debbie Downer?
Is that a hilarious story?
(Rachel laughs)
Well, it's fascinating.
Well, I was on a trip, and somebody that I didn't know,
there was this chit chat happening,
and someone asked a really downer question
and then I sort of filed it away,
and then it just popped into my head
and then I wrote it with Paula Pell,
Yes.
and, who is amazing,
and first when we were trying to write,
we set it in an office, it just wasn't really flowing,
and then we were like, wait, we have
to put this somewhere really, really happy,
so then we set it at Disney World.
(Ross laughs)
And Ana, what is your favorite character
and memory from SNL?
I guess it would be the music teachers with Will,
I think just in terms of, again--
I didn't know if you were gonna say you
and Molly doing NPR.
Very close, very close contest between NPR,
in terms of just, I like working and I like collaborating
and working with other people,
but I would say the music teachers,
just in terms of the inside lore of SNL.
We would start that sketch at earliest at 6:00 AM
on Wednesday morning,
and it was just like finals week in high school,
or in college, where it was just like,
we should start, but wait,
let me just tell you one more thing.
Oh my God, that is me in hair and makeup
with everyone every morning.
So we would laugh until we were blue in the face
about not things relevant to the sketch,
and then we would write the sketch and laugh that hard,
and then performing it was always fun too.
Thank you for what you both do, you guys, seriously.
Absolutely.
Thank you.
This is a love fest,
we love you.
All right, Ross,
you have to get to this story,
'cause it's my favorite one of the day.
Well, here, I'm obsessed with this.
It's up, up and away on Love Cloud, I'll explain.
The New York Times reports that's the name
of a new private flight service
that lets you officially join the mile high club.
Yep, for the low price of 90--
That is so gross.
I know.
$995, you get 45 minutes
in the air with a twin mattress covered in satin sheets,
and then when the deed is done, you just walk a way
with an official mile high club certificate,
signed by the pilot who, by the way,
will just be in the cockpit the whole time,
with a curtain, wearing noise-canceling headphones.
Can you guys believe?
No.
What are your thoughts immediately?
Ana, Rachel.
I picture maybe like 80% of these is some guy,
like, look what I got for us,
and the woman's like, oh,
I thought we were going somewhere fun.
Like, I thought they were going on a vacation,
and then like, no, you're just going up in the sky
for a quickie.
Some nasty silk sheets,
Nasty.
Somebody else has been laying in.
What do you think, am I being a prude here?
No, well, you get 45 minutes in the air,
but I wonder what you do with the last 41 minutes.
(all laugh)
(bright music)